I've been reading the research about Ibermectin, combating breast cancer stem cells on your site
from 324 and a few other places. Do you think it would be beneficial to take Ibermectin prophylaxically?
Or would this be something you would only try if you do breast cancer cells were present?
So there's a lot of people that take Ibermectin prophylaxically.
Do I? No. So if you don't have cancer or let's say you're in a, let's say your cancer is in a state of
remission, let's say you don't have cancer, or your cancer is in a good state of remission.
Personally, I wouldn't keep taking Ibermectin. There are also people that take Ibermectin prophylaxically
or other reasons. I mean during the COVID thing, a lot of people were taking Ibermectin prophylaxically.
The prophylactic dose of Ibermectin was typically about 3 milligrams. The dose of Ibermectin,
if you were not feeling well, you felt like you were exposed to COVID or you could come down with COVID
or you were sick with COVID was about, it's based upon weight, but the average person would take about
12 to 20 milligrams. The cancer dose of Ibermectin, you can calculate on the, the member,
the whole page of the member site, I gave you the calculation is based upon kilogram weights,
you got to convert your weight in pounds to kilogram, but let's say you weight, let's say you weigh 75
kilograms, then you would start with a half of a milligram per kilogram of weight. So if you
weighed 75 kilograms, you would take 37.5, or there are abouts milligrams of Ibermectin dose a day.
That would be an initial starting cancer dose. So, lots of times I'll talk to people on the
phone and they're saying I'm taking Ibermectin for my cancer. Oh, great. Well, it was prescribed by
such and such doctor for my cancer and I'm excited about it. Well, what dose you take it? 12 milligrams.
Okay, that's, that's not a cancer treating dose. So, the starting cancer treating dose is
one half of a milligram per kilogram of your weight. So you got to convert your weight to kilograms
and then divide that by half and that would be your starting dose, which is much higher than
the dose for COVID. It would be much higher dose than of a prophylactic dose. So, if I wasn't exposed
to a bunch of people that were sick, therefore, I'm thinking of a prophylactic dose.
Nor if my cancer was in remission or if I did a half cancer, personally, I wouldn't take it at all.
I would only take it if some crazy new virus was going around and I'm going to be exposed to it,
so I'm taking a prophylactic dose. Otherwise, I wouldn't use a medication, any medication that way.